-Oh, my goodness.
-Welcome back.
-Thank you. Thank you. It feel
good to be in the building
-In the building. You were here.
We were talking backstage.
An absolutely triumphant
"SNL" on Saturday.
-I had a lot of fun.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It was wonderful.
-It was great. It was fun.
-You seemed very comfortable
very confident,
which is, of course,
how we're used to seeing you
Did you have any butterflies
though?
-No. You know, I was telling the
cast, you know, it's only TV
-Yeah.
-It's just television.
You know, actually, I've bee
doing television for 38 years.
I started my career
in Atlanta, Georgia,
on public access television.
-Wow.
-And that was -- And, you know
anybody who had a camera
could get on television.
But, you know, it's funny --
What you were doing earlie
with the --
Remember in the '70s,
they used to do those --
Disc jockeys on radio
used to do those mashups
where they would have answers.
-Yes.
-And then they --
Is that where you got that from?
-No. We invented it.
It's very unique
and original to us.
And we did not know
that was a thing.
-Well, no.
You know, I think in '73,
I got my first
Panasonic tape recorder.
And I used to make those thing
where they would have,
you know,
Superman vs. Batman.
-Right, sure.
-And Nixon answers -- They wer
big hits on the radio stations
-What was your -- 38 years ago
What was your public access show
in Atlanta?
-Well, it wasn't mine.
It was called "The America
Music Show" in Atlanta, Georgia.
And, you know, when cable
came along, they had to allo
a certain amount of channels
for the public
because the cable stations
were using public ground
and wiring and stuff.
So anybody could have
a television show.
And, you know, here in New York,
remember the old
"Robin Byrd Show"?
-Yeah, I do remember
the "Robin Byrd Show," yes
-Yes. I think a lot of kid
may remember that.
-Yes.
It was an education, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-So, you know,
that's what I was doing.
-So you came to New York
from Atlanta.
-Yeah.
-And you sort of alluded to it
in your "SNL" monologue,
that it was an interesting tim
to be in New York,
that it had a lot
of great elements to it
in the '80s and '90s.
Because some people would sa
New York has been cleaned up
But there was a part of New York
that obviously was excitin
and dangerous.
-Well, no, but when I came her
in the 1980s...
No, it was still --
it was still dirty and fun
-Yeah.
-It was so much fun.
But, you know,
Giuliani really --
It was about '95
when it got cleaned up,
and I had left the scene
by then.
I don't know
if my leaving the scene
was part of how
it got cleaned up, but...
-"You know what? We might manage
to clean it up now.
We're not going to take it o
when RuPaul is here."
-No, but, you know, actually
when I got famous,
that's when the drag fun
ended for me, honestly
because, you know,
I couldn't terrorize
y'all's neighborhoods anymore.
-Yeah.
-Because I became
the face of drag, darling, yes
-Quite a burden,
I would imagine.
-Yes, it is. Well, you know,
I had to act nice and Christia
and everything.
As -- As much as I could.
-Well, I genuinely mean this -
By acting that way,
you have created this world,
now, in its 12th season.
This is a show that I thin
must have been hard for yo
to conceive
in the '80s and '90s.
This is a show that people watch
with their families.
-Yes. Yeah.
-This is a very --
It is a really fun,
entertaining show
with people being, you know,
kind and supportive.
And it's -- And that was -
Was that the world you kne
in the '80s and '90s
that people from the outside
would never have imagined?
-Yeah, well, no.
You know, listen.
Drag has never been really
for consumption for everybody.
Drag is dangerous.
It's politically incorrect
It's meant to provoke
different ideas.
But the fact that it's becom
this semi-mainstream thing
is mind-blowing.
In fact, on "Drag Race," we have
two premieres this season.
You get to see the first bunch
of girls in episode one.
And the second bunch of girls --
We say "girls." We use
that term loosely, okay?
In the second episode.
-That's really exciting.
You're also doing -- Live.
You have a live version
in Vegas?
-At the Flamingo Hotel,
there's a live version of
"Drag Race," which is great.
I also have a master class
which is coming out very soon,
and it is mind-blowing.
If you want to do drag,
if you want to understand
what it's about,
you got to see my master class
-Yeah.
-Yeah. It's really great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I also have a line of watche
I'd like to introduce you to
-You saw Nicki Minaj there
-Nicki Minaj!
-You obviously have
these celebrity guest judges
Do you have other fun ones
planned for this season?
-We have a lot, and, you know,
because I'm
an elderly gentleman,
I don't remember anyone.
-Perfect.
-I don't know any of them.
-We'll just assume they're there
and having a fun time.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.